the full scope of Russia's interference
in the 2016 election remains unclear a
new book out today provides one account
of Russia's assault on our democracy
it's called Russian roulette the inside
story of Putin's war on America and the
election of Donald Trump
it looks at Moscow's attacked from many
angles including the Trump campaign the
Obama administration and the independent
investigators who warned about what was
happening it's written by Yahoo News
chief investigative correspondent
Michael Isikoff and Mother Jones
Washington bureau chief David corn
welcome gentlemen
thanks for having us David let's start
with the House Intelligence Committee
they have found that the Russians were
not interfering in the election and
weren't out to help Donald Trump well
they have closed their investigation
without conducting all the interviews
that the Democrats wanted without
calling people back in for interviews
without subpoenaing a lot of information
and we've discovered just in the last
day that we have things in our book
which kind of is our home version
evident of the report that they have not
even bothered to look at and like what
well for instance they did not talk to
george papadapolis in our book we report
and remember he was the Trump campaign
aide who now has pled guilty to lying
who was trying to make contacts with
Russians to set up a meeting between
Trump and Putin and then later on just a
back-channel communication we've learned
for this book it's reported in the book
for the first time that he has told
molars investigators that Trump as he
believes it encouraged him he was at a
meeting with Trump and when he said I
could do this I can set up something
with with Putin Trump said to him
interesting though do it now we don't
know if that's the full truth but we do
know that the house investigating
committee hasn't even bothered to talk
to him so how can they know what Trump's
attitude was to these contacts between
the campaign and Moscow they don't even
talk to the guy who was doing it yeah
but you say both about Papadopoulos one
of the great names by the way and Carter
page not well-known in this country but
they're very well known in the in Moscow
because they're doing a lot of wheeling
and dealing on Trump's behalf there
and and it's pretty clear that once
Papadopoulos Carter page became members
of trumps foreign policy advisory team
that the Russians targeted them page
gets invited to give a speech at Moscow
these mysterious Russian contacts a
professor and a woman described as
Putin's niece reach out to him in London
and set up a meeting and inform him this
is Papadopoulos that the Kremlin has
dirt in the form of thousands of emails
on Hillary Clinton so this was macat the
totality of it it's clear that there was
a penetration campaign by the Russians
to get their hooks into the Trump
campaign that the Trump that they were
targeted and Trump sort of dismissed all
of this was oblivious to it and it's
been a mystery to some for some time
about why Donald Trump has refused to
criticize Vladimir Putin or say anything
really negative about him and in your
book you make it very clear why that is
he has been courting Vladimir Putin you
say since really December 2013 well he
has always wanted to have a big Tower
with his name on it and Moscow goes back
to 1987 actually spent decades trying to
do this he brought the Miss Universe
pageant to Moscow in 2013 and praised
Putin throughout that at the same time
while trying again to get a tower built
really Miss Universe was a an excuse for
him to get teamed up with a oligarch
named heiress Angela Rothen built a
tower and then that project didn't go
through but in 2015 while he's running
for president he is running for
president he is the leading Republican
in the pack he has a secret deal which
he doesn't tell the public about to try
to build another Tower again in Moscow
with a former fellow named Felix aider
and while he's doing this he's going on
air and shows all across the country and
praising Putin now he knows I can't
build a tower in Moscow without Putin's
approval so that's one reason then
people could say what does it have to do
with our election okay so he's trying to
build a tower in Moscow because okay
he's wheeling and dealing
what is that got to do with our alike
because the people he was trying to do
business in Moscow were the same people
were meddling in our election and trying
to sow discord and according to the US
intelligence community tilts the scale
in favor of Donald Trump so it's hard to
divorce those two events going on
virtually simultaneously assess the
Obama administration's handling of this
did they drop the ball here look that is
something we delve into deeply in the
book and we have a lot of new
information about what was going on
inside the Obama White House to try to
counter what the Russians were doing and
there were people on the White House
staff think the the chief cyber policy
coordinator who were trying to develop
aggressive options to go after the
Russians to counter what they were doing
cyber attacks on Russian news sites
exposing information about Putin's
corruption and wealth and they get told
by Susan Rice the national security
adviser to stand down knock it off you
don't we don't want to box the president
in because because they because the
president was not prepared to go there
he was worried that too aggressive
response would escalate create a cyber
war with the Russians and could actually
in some ways blow up the election could
create more chaos and therefore serve
Putin's needs the problem is that the
people on the White House staff were
saying no if you don't respond in real
time if you don't punch back when you've
been hit you know
it's sending a signal to the other side
whereas it was he's doing a little
acting but was President Obama there was
a real strong debate and in that debate
James clapper who's the Director of
National Intelligence said if we get
into this sort of cyber tit-for-tat
Russia could conceivably shut down our
electric grid we are more wired and
plugged in and dependent on cyber
infrastructure than Russia so there were
some real concerns that if you took this
step it might indeed make things worse I
mean it's very my favorite chapter of
the book
because it's sort of like what would you
do John Dickerson if you were in this
you know would the attack back would you
protect the election what would you do I
think you know you know each side
believes they took the right approach
obviously but I think it's fascinating
for a policy perspective well there's
lots more to read in the book you guys
for giving a preview here well thank you
david korn cool the name of the book is
called Russian Roulette and it's on sale
now the